[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم تتواصل في مصر حاله الجدل
السياسي بشان الاعلان الدستوري الذي اصدره
الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي الاسبوع الماضي
فكل معسكر مازال يصر على موقفه المعارضون
تظاهروا في ميدان لتحرير بالقاهره وبعض
المدن الاخرى يطالبون بالغاء الاعلان ولا
بديل عن ذلك في رايهم بينما اكتفى
المؤيدون بتجديد دعمهم للرئيس ولاعلان
الدستوري الذي يرونه بدايه لتحقيق اهداف
ثوره يناير نبدا النقاش عن المشهد السياسي
في مصر بعد هذا
التقرير اجواء ميدان التحرير تذكر بايام
الثوره انه فقط مفعول الصوره فل ليست ثوره
جديده ما اخرجت هؤلاء الى الشارع ولا هم
يدعون ذلك انهم معارض رئيس مصر المنتخب
والادق معارض اعلانه الدستوري الاخير لا
يرى فريق محمد مرسي في الاعلان سوى اداه
لتسريع الاصلاح وبناء مؤسسات الدوله لكن
خصومه وبينهم قوى سياسيه وثوريه يقولون ان
القرارات الاخيره كشفت ما يصفونها نزعه
مرسي
الاستبداديه وفضلا عن اسقاط الاعلان
الدستوري يطالبون باعاده تشكيل متوازنه
للجمعيه التاسيسيه بما يضمن صدور دستور
يعبر عن المصريين كافه انه تصعيد لاسوا
ازمه داخليه تشهدها مصر منذ انتخاب محمد
مرسي الصيف الماضي يبدو للبعض ان المعارضه
الليبراليه والقوميه واليسار في عمومها
تختبر هنا وفي مدن مصريه اخرى مدى قدرتها
على حشد التاييد لعلها نجحت في ذلك الى حد
كبير اما تحقيق مقصدها من هذا الحراك فمس
اله اخرى الاعلان الدستوري مثار الجدل بد
لكثيرين وكانما يستهدف في جانب منه السلطه
القضائيه ولذلك فان الرئاسه طمانت المجلس
الاعلى للقضاء بان تحصين القرارات
والقوانين يقتصر على السيادي منها وتلك
حصانه ستنتهي باقرار الدستور الجديد
وانتخاب مجلس شعب جديد تفسيرات الرئاسه
خطوه لا شك ترم التهدئه وقد اتبعها انصار
الرئيس بمثلها باتجاه خصومهم
السياسيين يتحدثون عن الرغبه في حقن
الدماء وتفادي الصدام ويعللون بذلك قرارهم
تاجيل تجمع لتاييد الاعلان الدستوري كان
مقررا امام جامعه القاهره ومع ذلك كله فان
المشهد لم يفرز مؤشرات الى ان فتيل الاز
قد نزع الدليل مظاهره المعارضه الحاشده
هذه ورفضها اي حوار مع الرئاسه قبل الغاء
الاعلان الدستوري وليس الجانب الاخر اقل
تمسكا بموقفه فلا استعداد واضحا من الرئيس
للتراجع عن عناصر خلافيه في اعلانه كتحصيل
جمعيه صياغه الدستور ثمه اذا حاله من
فقدان الثقه بين الجانبين حاله يخشى ان
تطول فتطول معها على مصر فترتها
الانتقاليه يسعدنا ان نستضيف في هذه
الحلقه السيد عصام سلطان وهو نائب رئيس
حزب الوسط كما ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف
السيد ايمن نور رئيس حزب غد الثوره ونبدا
باستطلاع الموقف معك السيد ايمن النور
ونسال هذا الحشد الان في ميدان التحرير ما
الهدف الحقيقي من ورائه مجرد رفض الاعلان
الدستوري ام ان هناك اهدافا اخرى كما
تابعنا في الشعارات التي
رفعت الحقيقه رفض الاعلان الدستوري هو
البدايه التي تجمع حولها هذا العدد الكبير
من البشر في مليونيه حقيقيه لكن لا شك ان
في
الخلفيه
تظهر مشاكل اخرى جزء منها فشل جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في تحقيق شراكه وطنيه
واضحه لا شك ان هنا حاله من حالات الغضب
بشان استئثار قوه بعينها السلطه واستئثار
بكل شيء في مصر هذا الفشل ترك مردود سلبي
على امور كثيره
وكانت الواقعه الاخطر في تقديره هي مساله
اصدار الاعلان الدستوري بغير التشاور بغير
حوار متضمنا بعض النصوص اللي بتحيي قيم
سلبيه نضلنا من اج من اجل مواجهتها قبل
الثوره سنوات طويله وبالتالي انا بتصور ان
الازمه الان هي ازمه شراكه وطنيه لم تتحقق
هي ازمه
روح انفراديه تزايدت في الفتره الاخيره
لذلك انا بعتقد ان الحل لابد ان يشمل ليس
فقط الغاء الاعلان الدستوري ولكن
ايضا اصلاح سياسي حقيقي وانا باشير هنا ل
مسالتين المساله الاولى اننا كنا في الازن
في اجتماع منذ يعني ساعات قليله جدا في
محاوله بين عدد كبير من القوى الوطنيه
لوصول الى حل الازمه ايضا اطلعت على
مبادره من الدكتور سيف عبد الفتاح مستشار
رئيس الجمهوريه تتضمن سبع نقاط اعتقد ان
هي مبادره جيده ان نبدا منها لحل للازمه
السياسيه بشكل عام لحل لفكره الشراكه
الوطنيه لحل لفكره الجمعيه التاسيسيه
والاعلان الدستوري انا بعتقد ان هذه
المبادره يمكن البناء عليها وصولا الى حل
لهذه الازمه الكبيره التي تفجرت والتي
ترجمت هذه الحشود الضخمه هل لنا ان نعرف
هل لنا ان نعرف تفاصيل هذه المبادره لو
سمحت سيد ايمن
نور يعني هو بيتحدث عن سبع نقاط ما اذكره
منها على وجه تحديد و بيتكلم عن اعلان
دستوري يشتمل الماده الاولى والثالثه هي
الماده الخاصه بالنائب العام والماده
الخاصه كمات ا بغض النظر عن موافقتي او
عدمه لان نستطيع ان نحقق الهدفين بغير
اعلان الدستوري لكن هو بيتكلم عن اعلان
دستوري يختصر الاعلان السابق في مادتين
فقط وبمعنى اصح هو بيلغي
المواد المفجره للازمه
زي قرارات الرئيس زي الماده الخاصه
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه اللي هم 66 وبيلي
معاهم بقيه المواد عدا الماده الاولى
والثالثه بيتكلم عن
استفتاء شعبي على بقاء المؤسسات التشريعيه
اللي هي الشعب والشورى والجمعيه
التاسيسيه بيتكلم عن اعاده اصلاح بعض
المؤسسات المنتخبه بيتكلم ان هو من خلال
تعيين عدد
كبير او عدد 100 شخص تقريبا في مجلس
الشورى يحدث توازن هذا المجلس اللي بيمثل
تيار واحد بيتكلم عن ضم اللجنه الاستشاريه
الى جمعيه سسيه باعتبارها اعضاء او
باعتبارهم اعضاء مع اضافه عره من قوى
سياسيه مختلفه ا يعني بيعيد التوازن ليسيه
وهذا امر مطلوب اي ب سيد اي سيد ايمن
الكثير الكثير في الواقع من التفاصيل التي
اعطيتنا اياها نرجو ان تبقى معنا طبعا
نتحول السيد عصام سلطان ضيفنا هنا في
الاستوديو سمعت لما ذكره السيد ايمن نور
قبل ان نخوض في تفاصيل هذه المبادره
بنقاطه السبعه التي اطلعنا على بعض منها
تحدث عن ربما ما وصف فه بفشل جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في شراكه بين مختلف
الاطراف وبالتالي الوصول الى هذه المبادره
ل
مستشار في الرئاسه السيد سيد سيف عبد
الفتاح الذي قدمها اذا اعلان دستوري يشمل
نقطتين فقط وربما التخلي عن النقطه
المتعلقه بتحصين قرارات الرئيس طبعا
تحياتي للصديق العزيز الدكتور ايمن نور
وهو دائما يعني طروحاته اقرب الى العمل
الوطني المشترك والخروج من الازمات وله
مساهماته يعني التاريخيه المشهوره وانا
اريد ان اعقب على نقطه هامه جدا وهي انه
ينبغي ان نفرق ما بين جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وبين مؤسسات الحكم والدوله
المنتخبه نحن بصدد اداء لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين او اداء لحزب الوفد او لحزب الغد
او لحزب الوسط او غير ذلك هذا فعلا هناك
نجاحات واخفاقات بالنسبه للجماعه ولغيرها
من الاحزاب الموجوده اما بالنسبه لمؤسسات
الدوله التي خرجت من اطار العمل الحزبي او
اطار الرؤيه الحزبيه الى اطار الاراده
العامه الشعبيه ممثله في مجلس الشعب مثلا
او في مجلس الشورى او في الجمعيه
التاسيسيه او في مؤسسه الرئاسه فهذا ما
ينبغي ان نتكلم فيه وان نحافظ عليه نحن
بصدد عمليه منظمه للاطاحه بكل هذه
المؤسسات اطيح بمؤسسه مجلس الشعب التي
يريد الان او يعني طرحها الدكتور سيف
في مبادرته واكد عليها صديقي العزيز ايمن
نور نحن بصدد الاطاحه يوم الاحد القادم
بمؤسسه مجلس الشورى وفي نفس اليوم الاطاحه
بالاعلان الدستوري الذي ابعد العسكر عن
الحكم بحيث ان المحكمه الدستوريه يوم
الاحد القادم سوف تعيد مره اخرى العسكر
الى الحكم مره اخرى نحن بصدد ايضا للاطاحه
بمؤسسه الرئاسه ايضا وبالتالي نحن بصدد
عمل منظم للاطاحه بالمؤسسات اي شيء
اي اي اي شيء يتعلق بهذا
الموضوع اي اي شيء يتعلق
بهذا ما نحن كنا بصدده منذ فتره قبل صدور
الاعلان الدستوري اننا كنا بصدد مطالبات
شعبيه للوقوف في وجه هذه الخطط الجهنميه
التي يتولاها ويشرف عليها ويتقنها النظام
القديم من هنا فانني يجب ان افرق اليوم في
مظاهره اليوم وفي ميدان التحرير اليوم
ويجب ان يفرق الجميع بين عدد لا باس به من
القوى الوطنيه الحقيقيه من قوى اليسار
والليبراليين وغير ذلك ممن يريدون فعلا
معنى استكمال مطالب الثوره والمشوار
الديمقراطي وبناء مؤسستنا وغير ذلك وهناك
اختلافات بسيطه وبين ان ينضم لهذا الحشد
الطاهر حشد اخر كان يريد ان يطل براسه عبر
كل مناسبه من المناسبات ووجد اليوم
مناسبته ووجد اليوم ضالته في ان يتواجد
مره اخرى بجوار زملائنا في الحركه الوطنيه
من اجل ان يحقق اهداف قديمه يجب ان نفرق
بين حاجتين في الاول بين جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين كاداء وبين مؤسسات الدوله لا ضير
ولا باس من ان الجماعه طبعا انا مع الصديق
العزيز ايمن نور نجحت وفشلت في كثير من
الامور وبين مؤسسات الدوله التي يجب ان
نقف كلنا كلنا لانها تمثل ارادتنا الحره
المنتخبه التي يعني ظهرت من خلال صناديق
الانتخاب والاستفتاءات وغير ذلك ايضا يجب
ان نفرق اليوم بين الواقفين ليسوا سواء
ليسوا على قلب رجل واحد هناك من فعلا يرفع
مطالب وطنيه حقيقيه وهناك من يريد اسقاط
ليس النظام ولكن اسقاط الاراده الشعبيه
التي جاءت بالمؤسسات المنتخبه الحقيقه ان
هناك مفارقه خطيره جدا سنعود سنعود الى
هذه النقطه سيد عصام سلطان لكن قبل ذلك
سننتقل الى فاصل قصير مشاهدينا الكرام على
ان نعود مره اخرى لاستئناف هذا النقاش
ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه الحلقه
التي تاتيكم مباشره من القاهره يسعدنا ان
نرحب بضيفنا الذي انضم الينا الان السيد
سليمان جوده رئيس تحرير جريده الوفد سيد
سليمان نعود ربما ونطرح التساؤل حول ما
يريده المت
ماذا بعد هذا الحشد في ميدان التحرير
الرئيس ربما حدد حدود الصلاحيات التي كان
يتحدث عنها وشملها الاعلان الدستوري لكن
ذلك كما يبدو لم يقنع المتظاهرين الذي
خرجوا اليوم الذين
خرجوا عايز بس اصلح صفه ان انا رئيس تحيه
الوفدي سابقا مش حاليا و اقول انه اتوقف
ايضا عند خبر بثه منذ قليل ان رئسه
الجمهوريه نفت استقاله المستشار محمود مك
نائب الرئيس وفي قاعده في الصحافه بتقول
احيانا ان نفي الخبر احيانا يؤكده واظن
انه نفي الخبر او ازاعه الخبر ثم نفيه على
بعض الفضائيات يدل على هناك ارتباكا في
مؤسسه الرئاسه في مواجهه ما يجري الان في
الشارع المصري وانها لا تدري ماذا عليها
ان تفعل في مواجهه هذه الحشود في ميدان
التحرير وفي ميادين اخرى على مستوى
الجمهوريه واذا كان للعقل ان يتغلب الان
من جانب مؤسسه الرئاسه فهو ليس امامها الا
ان تعود عن الاعلان الدستوري الذي صدر
مساء الخميس الماضي لان هذا الاعلان اذا
استمر سوف يؤدي الى نتائج او عق عواقب
كارثيه في الشارع المصري وا يعني انا يعني
استغرب انه احيانا يعني هناك من يدافع عن
الاعلان الدستوري ويعتقد انه في صف
القانون رغم انه انتهاك الاعلان للقانون
واضح وصريح لا لا اتكلم عن النائب العام
او عن المحاكمات هذه محل رضا من جزء في
الشارع وانما اتكلم عن تحصين قرارات
الرئيس هذه مساله غير مسبوقه عذرا فقط اود
ان استوقف هنا كان معنا السيد ايمن نور في
بدايه
البرنامج ولم تكن موجودا تحدث عن مبادره
تقدم بها سيف عبد الفتاح فعلا من نقطتين
متعلقه ب موضوع النائب العام وايضا
المحاكمات وتخلو من موضوع تحصين القرارات
الى اي مدى باعتقادك مثل هذه المبادره ان
ثبتت وان تم القبول بها وتطبيقها يمكن
فعلا ان تمتص الغ انا اشك ان هي تمر في
الشارع لانه هناك تصميم من جانب
ا ممثلي القوى الوطنيه في الشارع المصري
وخصوصا تصميم على ماذا لان هناك من يرى
بانكم تعرضون من اجل المعارضه وليس لشيء
اخر وانكم لم تكونوا يوما مع ال المشكله
هنا لم يفتعلها الذين الموجودين في الشارع
الان المشكله جاءت من جانب مؤسسه الرئاسه
وبالتالي فما هو في الشارع الان رد فعل
وليس فعلا وعلينا ان نفرق بين الفعل وبين
رد الفعل واذا انا اشك حتى انه مبادره
تمرير المحاكمات والنائب العام ممكن ان
تمر لان هناك تصميم من جانب المعارضين في
الشارع على اسقاط الاعلان الدستوري كاملا
اسقاط الاعلان الدستوري ام لنقولها بصراحه
اسقاط الرئيس محمد لا احد يتكلم عن اسقاط
الرئيس انا لا احد كلم عن اسات
الرئيس ربما يكون هذا انفعال يعني زائد عن
الحد في الشارع لكن الكلام العاقل الان هو
عن اسقاط الاعلان الدستوري واذا كانت
المؤسسه الرئاسه تبحث عن مخرج هناك فيقع
سيد سليم على تجميد الاعلان الدستوري هذا
مخرج يمكن ان يكون ملائما بصاص الهضب
الشارع الموجود الان والذي يذكرنا باحداث
ثوره يناير 2011 يعني اذا كان هذا الحشد
الاخوان ليسوا موجودين فيه فعلينا ان
نتصور اذا عند الرئيس مرسي واتبع رئس نظام
الرئيس السابق عندما كان يعاند مع الشارع
ويبحث عن ما يريده الشارع ويفعل عكسه فاذا
كان الشارع يريد الان اسقاط الاعلان
الدستوري فلماذا لا يستجيب له الرئيس محمد
مرسي ما حدود الصلاحات يعني فعلا هناك
سؤال سؤال جدي تطرحه ل العديد من الاطراف
ما حدود الصلاحيات التي يمكن ان ترضيكم
صلاحيات الرئيس محمد مرسي صلاحيات الرئيس
يعني يعني قبل ان يعلن هذا الاعلان
الدستور مساء الخميس المض لم تكن هناك
مشكله في صلاحيه الرئيس وكان الرئيس لديه
السلطه التشريعيه والسلطه التنفيذيه ولذ
فلم يكن ينقصه انه يتغول على السلطه
القضيه بهذا الشكل ولم يكن ينقص ان هو
يؤسس لنفسه او او يستولي على سلطه التاسيس
وديت يعني يكفي ان الدكتور يحي الجمل
والدكتور حسام عيسى والدكتور ابراهيم دريش
والكبار اساه القانون الدستوري بيروا ان
الرئيس ليس من حقه ان يؤسس لاعلان دستوري
او او يصدر اعلانا دستوريا الان وفق
الاعلان الدستوري الذي صدر في مارس 2011
وعليه ان يحترم الاعلان الدستوري الذي جاء
على اساسه رئيسا منتخبا وانا يصدر اعلانا
دستوريا بشكل الذي صدر به مساء الخميس
الماضي وبالتالي فالحل هو اسقاط الاعلان
واذا كان اسقا اسقاط اذا كانت كلمه
الاسقاط يعني تقلل من شان او تمس الرئاسه
فيمكن تجميد الاعلان الدستوري وضح تماما
لا نتحول السيد عصام ونصوح رايه في هذا
الطرح هو في كذا جزئيه سريعه الجزئيه
الاولى فيما يتعلق بما تضمنه الاعلان
الدستوري من اتساع لسلطه الرئيس فيما
يتعلق بتحصين قراراته هذا الامر فعلا كان
محل جدل حتى مساء امس لكن هو تم الحسم فيه
تم الحسم بالضبط بالضبط كده بالضبط كده
وتم الحسم فيه باجتماع
ضم كبار رجال القضاء في مصر اعلى قمه هرم
القضائي في مصر هم اعضاء مجلس القضاء
الاعلى وبالتالي هذا الموضوع اعتقد انه
موضوع اصبح واضح
تماما باقي مضامين الاعلان الدستوري جاء
توقيا لحاله من الترتيب تحدث ولعل الصديق
العزيز الاستاذ سليمان يؤيدني في هذا حاله
من التصعيد عبر بعض الرموز الموجوده في في
عدد من السلطات الموجوده المصريه المؤسسات
العميقه مؤسسات الدوله المصريه العميقه
سينتهي يوم الاحد القادم باحكام نحن نعلم
طبيعه هذه الاحكام من خلال الصحف يعني
بمجرد حضرتك ما تقري صحيفه او تدخلي على
موقع تقرا تصريح لاحد القضاه الذي هو عضو
في محكمه ستنظر في الملف يوم الاحد القادم
يعني هذا الشيء لم يكن يتصوره احد في
تاريخ القضاء المصري القائم على تقاليد
عتيده راسخه وفي تاريخ القضاء في العالم
كله لا يمكن قاضي يخرج ويتكلم في الصحف و
يقول رايه مثلا في جمعيه تاسيسيه انها كذا
وصفتها ونعتها هذا امر مقبول من استاذ
سليمان هذا امر مقبول من الصحفيين
والسياسيين وغير ذلك ولكن من قض اذا اه
طيب ماذا يعني يوم الاحد القادم كان يعني
الانهاء على ما تبقى من مؤسسات منتخبه نحن
عندنا مؤسسه مجلس الشعب المنتخبه تم
الاطاحه بها عندنا مؤسسه الشورى سيطا بها
يوم الاحد القادم عندنا مؤسسه الجمعيه
التاسيسيه سيطح بها عندنا اعلان دستوري
صدر
في 11 اغسطس من الرئيس مرسي الغى الاعلان
الدستوري المكمل الذي كان يعطي سلطات
للمشير والفريق سيوقف تنفيذ هذا الاعلان
الدستوري الصادر من رئيس الجمهوريه بما
معناه ومؤداه
عوده الجيش مره اخرى وعوده المجلس العسكري
مره اخرى اذا نحن يوم الاحد القادم نتجه
الى الانهاء التام على كافه مؤسسات الدوله
المنتخبه والاتيان بالمجلس العسكري مره
اخرى ليدير شؤون هل هذا ما تريدون سيد
سليمان هل الوضع فعلا كذلك هل هذا ما
تريده المعارضه الان وهل هي قادره اصلا
على المضي بهذا الموضوع في هذا الاتجاه
يعني اعتقد انه ده غير دقيق في اجماله
لانه انا اريد ان اذكر هنا بان قيادات
جماعه الاخوان وعلى راسها الدكتور محمد
مرسي نفسه قبل الثوره كانوا يطالبون
بالغاء مجلس الشورى الذي يحصون الان يعني
ارجاع حضرتك الى ما كان الاخوان يقولونه
قبل الثوره كانت هناك مطالبات قويه وحاده
بالغاء مجلس الشورى نهائيا الان ال ان
يحصن مجلس الشورى يعني هذا التناقض غير
مفهوم لدى الشارع المصري نم اثنين
التاسيسيه اذا حلت التاسيسيه فلماذا لا
ننشئ تاسيسيه جديده ما هي المشكله في
الاستعجال في وضع الدستور بهذه الطريقه
الا اذا كان الغرض هو ان يسيطر فصيل معين
على على الدستور الجديد تونس لديها عامين
لوضع دستور جديد ما ما وجه العجله في ان
يوضع دستور جديد لمصر بهذه الطريقه الا
اذا كان هناك هدف معين حكايه ال اذا هي
ازمه ثقه حقيق اذا هو تاكيد على الكلام لا
يعني ير يعني هذه المؤسسات من اين اتت
التاسيسيه من اين اتى الشورى من اين ا اتى
من اين من اراده الشعب مش عاجبني او مش
عاجبك موضوع ثاني يعني انا انا متحفظ على
هذه المؤسسات وادائها قطعا لابد ان يكون
هناك راي محترم يتحفظ على
التاسيسيه انا رايي انه يعني هذا الكلام
الذي يكون عن مؤامرات كانت تحق ضد الرئيس
او ضد مؤسسه الرئاسه كلام غير دقيق والا
فعلى الرئيس ان يقدم الادله دامغه عليه
لانه الرئيس في خطابه يوم الجمعه اللي فات
الكلام غامض والناس حتى الان تتساءل ماذا
يقصد ومن يقصد عندما يتكلم رئيس الجمهوريه
فيجب ان يقدم معلومات لا ان يقول كلاما
مرسلا عندما يقول ان هناك كانت مؤامرات
يجب ان يكشف عن المؤامرات وان يقول اطراف
المؤامرات هي كذا وكذا والا فان احنا امام
كلام عام لمجرد تبرير هذه الاجراء هذا
الاعلان الدستوري الذي لا لن يمر يعني شكل
الشارع الان بيشير الى ان الاعلان
الدستوري لا يمكن يمر فلماذا المعانده مع
الشارع المصري لماذا العناد مع الشارع
المصري لماذا رفض يعني الموجودين في
الميادين الان جزء منهم انتخب الرئيس مرسي
مش هنقول كلهم جزء من ولكنه الان ضد الذي
صدر عنه وضد الاعلان الدستوري ويطالبه
باسقاطه لا احد يطالب باسقاط الرئيس على
الاطلاق المطلب الاساسي هو اسقاط الاعلان
الدستوري وعدم المساومه حوله لا يمكن ان
احنا نتكلم عن حته في في الاعلان الدستوري
ونسيب حته الاعلان الدستوري
مجملا وعلك تعرفين ان هناك قضاه الان
دخلوا في اعتصام مفتوح في نادي القضاه
انتهى وقتنا للاسف شديد للاسف الشديد نحن
الان جزء من الصوره وليس في كل الصوره كان
هناك مليونيه كانت ستقوم حينئذ كانت ربما
تكون المقارنات فيتكلم اخواننا
الليبراليون واليساريون على ان العمليه مش
بحشد مش بالعدد فانا اريد ان ننسى اننا
نرفض الاحتكام للعد واضا للسيد عصام انتهى
وقتنا للاسف الشديد تماما عصام سلطان نائب
رئيس حزب الوسط اشكرك جزيل الشكر كما نشكر
ضيفنا السيد سليمان ج رئيس تحرير جريده
الوف سابقا ونشكركم مشاهدينا الكرام على
طيب المتابعه بهذا نختم حلقه ما وراء
الخبر دمتم في رعايه الله والسلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم